The approach we're instead going to take is based on a different hashing algorithm, non-chaining,
and this hashing algorithm is called cuckoo hashing.
This is a cuckoo bird; thanks, Wikipedia.
And it's termed a brood parasite, but let's put it into more understandable English.
This bird is one of the biggest jerks in the animal kingdom.
Rather than taking care of its own eggs and chicks,
it instead lays its eggs in another bird's nest,
throwing out the other bird's eggs to make room
and let's the other bird raise its chicks.
See if you can detect why the algorithm I'm about to describe is called cuckoo hashing, as I describe it.
The key to this method is having multiple hash tables instead of just 1.
Multiple hash functions, 1 per hash table.
And those hash tables only allow 1 item in each one of their buckets.
There is no chaining in this algorithm at all.
In the example we'll show, we're going to have 2 hash tables and 2 hash functions,
but the method generalizes to more than 2.
So here's where we're going to do at a high level.
First, all the items that we want to hash,
we use the first hash function and try to hash into the first hash table.
Some of them will collide and fail, and by that, I mean, we're going to try write multiple items into the same bucket,
but we're only allowing 1 item per bucket.
That's okay; if n items try to write into 1 hash bucket,
we only require that 1 of them succeeds, and it doesn't really matter which one.
So then those that fail--we're going to take all the ones that are leftover that failed,
and we're going to use the second hash function to try to hash into the second hash table and so on.
Now the cool part is what happens next,
but we're going to go and take an example here
and I'm going to show you how it works,
and then we'll see exactly how this cuckoo hashing works.